welcome to episode number six of the
check-in I know this is a little bit of
a weird way to start but I got a phone
call from Joey a few minutes before we
started recording the podcast that is
the reason we started the podcast is the
phone calls that I get from Joey just
like this Joey is having a hard time
logging into our recording and this is a
few of my favorite moments from it enjoy
it before the episode of the check-in
thank you guys enjoy the episode I can
also just read you the link if you need
me to to for you to type it
in
type it into what to Chrome if you can't
if you can't get into your email if you
can get into Chrome or Firefox I have a
link for you that I could just read to
[Laughter]
you make set up your browsing a few
simple
steps add bookmarks to your favorite
Google app don't worry about that
skip what the
[__]
what it say pick a backround pick
whatever one you
like I don't know what the options are I
think they're just colors [__] got by
okay gec shapes perfect the one let
do continue all sign Chrome don't worry
about
it
okay email don't worry about it you
don't have to do any of this we can do
this later if you want I'm telling you
says I'm try to hit next [__]
are
relent people a [__]
Rel throw me into a trap what kind of
trap is Google gonna set for you hold on
I think I put it together I got do thing
select all images with
cars I gota play [__]
yeah it's the same thing I sign up for
[__] s me with this
[__] they need to make sure you're not a
robot yeah then they keep sending this
[__] like two hours like
cars there you go there's the car
there's the car
might I always get this one wrong
I all right I'm not a
robot okay can you can you type in the
address at like the website at the
top what
website slash okay s
I
won't so if you after s
is no I just as you type it in I'll say
it you know I'm I understand that I'll
go very slow and speak very loud all
right so it's
s s s is in
Sam all right
six six
seven seven ni
two Jay as in
Jacob
six seven another seven another there's
another one too all right
six
j6 all right let's go back
to and then hit
enter all right enter the studio there
we go boom there you go
[__] turn off your TVs run for
your lives it's over they didn't put you
on this planet just to give up if Uncle
Joey could do it I can rule the world
that's what you got to be thinking
welcome back to show
[Music]
no